eu venho aqui falar ensinar e aprender a
dizer só serem dos conceitos que estão
normalmente associado a outro não são
mais brinquedos - basta pensar que
qualquer nova chuva já deve ter uma
experiência de aprender alguma coisa
porque sozinho mas ninguém conseguiu
ensinar
se não houver ninguém do outro lado quer
aprender alguma coisa nós enquanto durar
esta apresentação vamos porque assim
podem quero aprender lá é e epal estamos
também durante a apuração desta
apresentação mais lava ensinar o quadro
aprender a dançar enquanto investigador
é estar nos mas tem habituado a aprender
coisas novas e nos tentam enquadrar as
frustrações insatisfações da prf a gente
imagina só formato ensinar a mesmo
estando lá ensinaria outro a receber
mais apanha me se faltava saber convosco
o que mais difícil para se levantarem
é tudo pensarmos como é que é uma
aprendizagem que foi feita
vamos nós já muito sempre o lançamento
tem que aprender a dar uma criança tem
nada conhecem os é que os pais fumam a
criança olha o brinquedo que assim vão
fazer lá e ficaram brinquedo ou então
até os pais que nós sempre colocamos a
bola e por exemplo plantar não preciso
ficar na rua
é o que falta uma criança é nestas
circunstâncias é falta
falta um fosso é eventualmente vai
aprovar hoje um esforço que precisa ter
que pagar e evitar é em falta de crença
tem uma derrota maior problema mas
queria que você pensava criança queria
fazer os cursos
então vamos por exemplo um carro inteiro
lá no fundo do court uma criança mal vê
ou então também podemos pensar em deixar
a criança numa escala que agora está à
venda na área para garantir que ela faz
desenhos em março e na lista é o que eu
falei deixar os brinquedos um pouco fora
do alcance da criança e pensa vai
aprender a andar num lugar que não tem
grande onde está o pai não dava é agora
um pouco mas vai perceber a primeira a
ter um susto quando as forças de paz das
frutas e vai levá lo ao se tornar legal
a usar aquela que ela veja é assim eu
estava de malas em dezembro estudos
feitos pela tecla da tarde a discussão
do álbum em si
queria ter alguma motivação curitiba e
aprendizagem a exclusividade para fazer
esforço eventualmente alguma alguma
coisa é o município probatório
apresentado é o dos pesados numa
situação mais cento nas nossas vidas e
que é tentar ser que fiquem fora em boa
forma física
vamos pensar no ginásio no ginásio que
você é o reconhecimento conseguido
através do grito de incentivo e
novamente com ela
então imagina nem por um minuto que
estavam na sala e os avatares é difícil
tem toda vez não houve suspensão
melhor nas mãos de outra matéria porque
parte está em consulta e tratamento é
que eu escuto muito grande e funciona em
primeiro lugar a um time agora a pessoa
vai explicar uma forma se isso vai ter
um exemplo ficaram em segundo lugar está
uma muito importante
quem vai treinar vai ter uma difícil
crise e vai casar e mais o ar e mais
fars
afinal pontos ninguém espera poder
barriga quando outras coisas a fazer a
unidade
então vamos fazer um tempo por eles para
os estudantes
o atlético é sim estudar como é que você
só podia conseguem acreditar que
aprendem alguma coisa tem estado por
trás da professora resolver um problema
está acontecendo em seu lugar no ginásio
possível escolher qual é o tipo do
treino nós vamos fazer é possível que
elas grupo é possível utilizar as
máquinas peso é piloto a mãe anos
alinhado com a companhia
é um show que nós vamos fazer é fazer
vai nos estados unidos no dia seguinte
só tem mais coisa assim mas não já
completamente incapacitado e portanto a
rua não tem cuidado por parte do esforço
e então um certo ponto que é observar a
calcular que escolhas já foi a segunda
nas preferências de todos nós no posto
isto eu estava em aula também nos dizer
que nós passamos a vida real para o
ensino universitário como é que não é
menos real
é bom então era fiel desenvolvemos um
projeto pedagógico que que oferece uma
imagem blenda clã basicamente combina
ensino presencial com ensino à distância
e isso tudo certo vários fizeram
aprendizagem dos estudantes que estão
habituados a uma aprendizagem mais
tradicional ao estado mais tecnológicos
eram estudantes que tenham necessidade
de trabalhar a equipe por exemplo alguns
são mais individualistas protegem o
objectivo é espanhol sport é o objetivo
do curso é que o estudante possa formar
suas preferências e para isso é é isso
mesmo o excesso de recursos pedagógicos
alguns são complementares assim outros
documentários e outros ainda
eventualmente até igual conteúdo mas o
fez se luz em suporte distinto e nada
mesma mensagem pode passar a usar
veículos distintos e isso altera
completamente a forma como o estudante
aprende é a mensagem que é tratar a
menina a forma como el tanque dos
tradicionais apontamentos de aula
a proposta desse trabalho que
normalmente são trabalhadas em aulas
presenciais também é oficina do
estudante como um software que permite
que este possa aplicar o que aprendeu
as situações na vida real e até as
situações que exigem maior dimensão a
qual não podiam dar a resposta se não
fosse o software é na componente online
do curso é de usar todo o material e
software que funciona em todas as
plataformas
e se está lá em cima colo e que todos
têm acesso em qualquer altura e em e na
forma em que mancharia o estado tem à
sua disposição um teste xeque a questão
dos cruzados no final de cada módulo
encostando pode ter a pretensão da forma
do seu estado
o motivo no curso os fãs têm à sua
disposição um teste de autoavaliação e
nos anos anteriores
em pronunciamento ao vale no sentido de
saber a forma como está a adquirir ou
não as portuguesas que são extintas
isso tudo é muito importante
a avaliação é que afete o esforço que o
estudante tem no processo de
aprendizagem durante todo ano são
disponibilizados também os laboratórios
da experimentação
apenas ouvimos em grupo estava na aula
ou então laboratório digitais que os
estudantes podem utilizar a fóruns de
discussão em que os estudantes respondem
interagências riscos são provocados por
cento
daí a almas é indiscutível de que fazem
no trabalho para que os alunos possam em
luque também poder discutir alguns
assuntos e permite até ao aluno poder
preparar esses materiais em casa e
funcionaria a gente foi pitty em que no
fundo vamos usar mais as aulas para
aperfeiçoar o que aprenderam e
resolverem o número é a chamada de
atenção mas é linda e links e conteúdos
para internet sobre assuntos
relacionados com as matérias vão ser
leccionados por que não vivemos um mundo
isolado o que aprendemos aqui está sendo
ensinado em todo o mundo e aplicada em
todo mundo e temos claro o atendimento
personalizado ao santos que é presencial
que é bom ainda vivia só este ano
então mesmo sem conhecer as políticas de
seu perfil é agora indo exatamente
colocar os aos novos problemas à saúde
acho que esses auxiliares suicida
atendimento pessoal e portanto ela
prefere uma aprendizagem trânsito
já a mariana aprendi a tecnologia dá
valor aos materiais que podem usar via o
seu tablet um software para explorar as
matérias que aprendeu e inútil dúvidas o
marco nos fóruns em abundância
participar do estado das das aulas
a intenção do grupo e por thaçi
vivenciam perfil de aprendizagem mais de
compressão mundial com os coisas pro
amor comigo para alto mar como em
doenças adianta correta tudo e mais
alguma coisa
bom então o que queremos com isto
ilustrar que o sol se é que nós temos
vários recursos para que o estudante
possa adquirir um conjunto e que
combinam em perfis de aprendizagem
a mensagem que queremos passar
o importante é que o estudante também
ganha no saldo que tem que descansar e
isso é com fundamental o seu esforço e
pode ser acumulado com recursos fossem
obrigados é o facto de estar
o estudante popular do estudante é mais
que iam tem que tentar ultrapassar isso
é dor e eu tenho que tentar outra
passado as limitações que são colocadas
pela bela produção daquilo que vê como
já foi aqui falava entre membros e mais
para tentar passar a investir lá se
criar e usar os conteúdos quebrando para
criar e portanto a dor associada está
mais toxicidade que vai ter que pensar
essa dor pro tomada em indiana ou
minimizada pelo facto do estudante via
das suas preferências reguladas porque
iam quem escolhe os recursos que quer
usar nesse processo todo no centro é um
ex presidente que tenta ajudar a estudar
no seu percurso mas é estudado e
conhecido como o pai do meu filho e
tenta parado no processo de brinquedo
mas a criança que ensina qual o caminho
que quer seguir aqui é um ponto muito
importante que é o da avaliação ea
convenção realmente é um processo muito
é um ponto importante no no primeiro dia
a avaliação consistirá lia a motivação
incrível e o esforço que temos vindo a
falar fato o estudo sala desde o início
do curso que é mensal é um momento em
que o estudante possa mostrar e
demonstrar aquilo que sabe que o que
aprendeu e não acontece muitas vezes e
portanto da barra
todos nós sabemos dessas histórias 12
meses o estudante vai vitória em vitória
até o final e é isso que queremos evitar
nossa metodologia
o estudante é é quem toma as opções e
ela é linda nas suas coisas e isso faz
com que o destino e isso é o sinal bom
tudo que conquistei aqui falar ainda não
especificados do curso é que temos
estado a tratar da questão tecnologia e
podem aplicar a qualquer custo a matéria
é diferente não é possível dissociar uma
coisa foi que enquanto a matéria foi
enfim uma mera troca roubar qualquer das
formas não queremos terminar
obrigado